it's time to play america's favorite
game show 68 from
600
all right here is how the game show
works if a player can answer six
questions correctly
from six feet away in 60 seconds they'll
win
600.
i know and if they answer less than six
questions correctly
they'll go home with a consolation prize
which is a lovely state-of-the-art
six-pack
today we have three players and three
categories
they are num num num num it's food for
thought
and then we have adorable animals oh
and finally pop music all right i love
these categories okay
our first player is kelly come on out
kelly
bye kelly you're so pretty
thank you you too oh so lovely oh you
also i love the green oh my god
patrick's would you have to do that yeah
if there wasn't covet i'd come over and
pinch you oh my gosh
um all right well you live in new paltz
i do and you are an analyst is that
right
personal analyst yup all right well
what's one secret we don't know about
you
i used to work on a cruise ship hey yeah
yeah that's so fun isn't that bad oh it
was really fun oh my gosh
did you like was it like below deck also
yes
yeah oh yeah lots of partying i love it
um kelly what category of the three are
you choosing oh
man um i think i'll do
num num num it's food for thought girl
after my own i got him man
all right here we go we're gonna start
the clock at 60 seconds okay okay you
ready
okay all right kelly here we go yes yes
yes all right start the clock what food
is hummus made from chickpeas or
potatoes chickpeas yes
in the movie e.t what candy did e.t
enjoy rick popper reese's pizzas reese's
pieces
how many eggs are in a dozen 12 or 18.
12. yeah
duh it's an avocado a fruit or a
vegetable a
fruit in beyonce's song formation she
sings
i got blank in my bag is it hot sauce or
mayonnaise
hot sauce it should be
43 seconds oh god which cartoon
character was known for eating spinach
popeye or jet set popeye
yes oh my gosh mike i am so excited
take it away
thank you oh thank you for playing and
thank you for being so smart and
beautiful
thank you thank you okay let's bring out
our next player emily
hi oh my god
dude i am digging your hair thank you
thank you it's new it's recent oh i love
it thank you drew
it's mutual thank you you live in new
york city and you're an editor
i am an editor yes oh i know editors
yeah i'm sure i love them thank you you
have the and you're in charge of the
narrative you can skew things really one
way or another
fix or save things yeah it's like the
last step in the line nobody really
knows that what's one secret about you
um i speak a little bit of chinese but
don't ask me to prove it you know what i
mean
what's awesome yeah you have uh do you
know like rad awesome
great anything jubilant in chinese um
i can say washoe jungwin kesha jungwin
shaw de buhau which means i speak
chinese but i don't speak it very well
oh my gosh i love it i think you
actually do speak it nailed it
okay we have adorable animals and pop
music left would you like to choose pop
music
great all right here we go let's start
the clock ready
okay alifia moore is the real name of
which artist
pink or madonna no idea great pink
yes music festival did everyone headline
in 2018 coachella or south by southwest
coachella
yes yes which one of these titles is an
instinct song i want you back or i want
it that way i want it that way
no no in 2010 lady gaga wore a dress
made out of what at the vmas vegetables
are meat
meat yes which artist performed at the
super bowl this year
the weekend or shakira the weekend yeah
yes john paul george ringo are better
known as what group come on
the beatles yes what does mtv stand for
music television yes yes that's sick
oh my god yeah emily
yes mike is going to bring you
the heart thank you and you have 600
happy st thank you
all right thank you it's time for our
last player please welcome
marquesa
[Music]
how are you i'm so happy to see you
i'm so happy to see you too marquez
you're from new york city and you're a
technology engagement speaker i
am but can you tell us one secret about
yourself
let's see one secret about myself
is i moved to new york city with a dream
almost 30 years ago and i'm living my
dream so it's true what they say
you can have your dream in new york city
and my dream is i help people
look fabulous on zoom well
maybe you can do a segment on the show
for us to teach people some tips
i would love to all right we're down to
adorable animals you ready
i'm ready i love every single animal i
see you and my daughter marquesa okay
ready start the clock what is the
smallest breed of dog chihuahua or
golden retriever
chihuahua what is the popular children's
show barney what kind of animal was
barney
barney yeah a dog it was a dog
no a cat dinosaur a rat color is an
arctic fox white or purple
purple not white yeah it's white okay
when a baby giraffe starts to walk
within an hour of being born
or is it nine months within an hour
what is the biggest animal on the planet
african elephant or the blue whale
garfield the cat hates one certain day
of the week which is it
mondays or thursdays
mondays i love mondays are humans
consider to be amphimians
or mammals what i know
i'm mammals apparently my cats are said
to have how many lives
catch nine lives
[Music]
by the way i totally was like oh or no i
don't know the amphibians are mammals
so we were both like there you go
thank you bye goodness yes okay let me
just bend down
all right here we go oh my question mark
i'm so
happy that you won 600
all right thank you everybody for
playing that's all we have today for
six feet from six hundred dollars
you